so good evening and welcome to our
biggest event so far in 2018 I'm Bradley
Graham the co-owner of politics and
prose along with my wife Lissa Muscatine
and on behalf of everybody in P&P and
everybody here at six and I thank you so
much for coming
you know January historically is a
rather slow month in the book business
especially relative to the fevered pace
of sales during the holiday season but
thanks to Michael Wolfe the last few
weeks have seemed well like a second
Christmas from many booksellers given
the surge in demand for Michael's book
fire and fury one frequent question I've
been asked is whether there's any
precedent for this sort of frenzy of
course we've had bestsellers before and
seen people standing in long lines for
them and normally were able to
anticipate at least roughly how many
books to order but the velocity and
volume of requests for fire and fury
seemed to take everyone by surprise our
events team did have the foresight weeks
ago before the books release to schedule
Michael for an author talk but it was at
our new smaller store at the wharf which
could have accommodated only about 1/4
of the crowd here this evening so let's
all give a giant round of applause to
the terrific staff here at 6 and I
they they they made this spacious venue
available and enabled many more people
to attend and while we're at it let's
also clap for Henry Holt and company a
part of macmillan which faced with a
legal threat pressuring them not to
publish instead rushed out distribution
of the go
because but because of all the attention
that Michael and his book has received
I'm going to assume everyone here
already knows what's in fire and fury
while there's been controversy about the
accuracy of some parts and whether they
should be taken literally a number of
journalists who have covered this White
House have said much in the book rings
true and can be taken seriously as
further evidence calling into question
Donald Trump's fitness to be President
Michael himself has a long track record
in journalism dating back to the mid
1970s when he worked as a New York Times
copy boy he's been a columnist for New
York magazine Vanity Fair The Hollywood
Reporter and other publications he's won
several magazine awards and written six
previous books his edgy reporting and
writing style has made him no stranger
to controversy as one New York Times
profile of him putted he's quote picked
up as many foes as fans during his years
as a slashing columnist we certainly
appreciate him taking time to appear
here this evening he'll be in
conversation with John Jonathan Capehart
who's been a member of the Washington
Post's editorial board for a decade and
is a Pulitzer Prize winning writer
Jonathan also hosts the podcast kpop and
contributes to MSNBC I've watched
Jonathan moderate before and he comes
very prepared so we should be in for a
great discussion ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming Michael
Wolfe and Jonathan Capehart
[Applause]
sir look what you've done
are you this is really terrific thank
you and thank you all for coming this is
great okay before I get to the how I
wanted to start this I was curious that
I mentioned this to to Michael this is
Washington DC a book event for a book
that has set this town on fire and I was
curious I was wondering who who's here
are they we're in a at least in terms of
party registration a democratic city but
in terms of power the House the Senate
in the White House are Republican
control so Michael said well I'd be
curious to find out too so I don't know
if anybody how many Democrats are here
okay how many Republicans are here oh
come on oh okay fine let me put it this
way how many people involved in the
political process are here okay all
right a lot of shy people okay so
Michael on Saturday Night Live last week
there cold over the cold open was a
send-up of Morning Joe and Fred Armisen
played you and the willie Geist
character asks this now Michael there
have been several errors pointed out in
this book already dearest do you take
responsibility for those Michael wolf
look you read it right everyone says
yeah
Michael wolf says and you liked it you
had fun
everyone says yeah then Michael wolf
says well what's the problem you got the
gist so shut up you know even the stuff
that's not true it's true
what's your reaction to that portrayal
Michael Mann so now I have to
deconstruct that's the world we're in
now Mike it's all true
it is literally all true
this book is Donald Trump in full there
is an eye you know I think there's a
minute that you know there's I have the
problem with the Berman brothers Mark
Fuhrman and somebody else Berman who I
seemed to have transposed you know and
and to this I I entirely copped to my
fault but about Donald Trump this book
is as true as it gets this is the man
and I think it's one of the reasons that
that this book has this remarkable thing
has happened happened to this book that
we all thought and even I thought this
writing this I thought we know Donald
Trump we've we've we've captured this
and it turns out I think that we hadn't
that the story of Donald Trump this kind
of emotional void we had been sort of
circling around looking into but not
really being able to to grasp what this
this thing is and and I think I'm I
think that's the that's the
accomplishment of this book
now during an interview on MSNBC with
Katie Turk I believe she asked you
because a lot of people are saying well
if you've got tapes recordings of these
interviews you should you should release
them with her I believe that was on a
Monday or Tuesday you said you said no
when I interviewed you on MSNBC a couple
days later you sort of backtracked and
said you know I'm kind of thinking about
it but
I don't know so now that we are a week
out a week later where is your head in
terms of the question of I mean I've
been doing this for a rather long time
and I have always had you know I work
like everybody else works you have you
son sometimes you have tapes sometimes
you have notes sometimes you run to the
bathroom to scribble what someone has
just told you and I I have never in my
career been asked for tapes before so I
thought well that's not what we do and
what I do is not make tapes what I do is
is write sentences but maybe I'm wrong
maybe in in a multimedia world this is
what has to happen and and when people
have asked me this question I thought oh
my god now I got to get a sound engineer
now I gotta get what how do you do this
but but maybe maybe maybe I mean there's
a lot of it's it becomes somewhat
complicated because there are a lot of I
have a lot of people on tape who I have
sworn on my life that I would not reveal
I mean you go through this process in in
which you make a series of deals and
sometimes the deals are I will talk to
you but if someone asks me if I have
talked to you I will deny it and you
have to promise me that you will not
contradict that and that's the deal you
make so I guess I can't I mean unless
I'm completely immoral which I seem to
be often accused of being at least I'm
not that amoral and but on the other
hand you know I I got Steve ban and on
tape and and the the Bannen tapes are
riveting I mean
somebody I mean if you haven't read the
book the banning pieces are like wow
alright so I want to get him in he opens
his mouth and it's a kind of poetry a
committee a poetry of a sort of us well
all poetry is of a sort right well I
wouldn't I mean you cannot stop
listening to it you just go you think oh
I hope it keeps going and does so I'm
gonna ask you this question to get into
your sources and how you got them it
early in the book there is a you you
tell you talk about this dinner party
that is thrown Roger Ailes is there
everyone's waiting for for Steve Bannon
to to show up he's hours
he's hours late but when he gets there
he is just going on and on and on and on
and on in the book it is not clear who
is throwing the dinner party but we now
know that the dinner party was thrown by
you now and I bring that up for a
specific reason which I'll get to later
but on the view you were asked by Megan
McCain whether the dinner was off the
record and you initially said yes the
dinner was off the record which you
could hear the gasp in the audience of
people who knew what that meant
and she asked so then how is this
off-the-record dinner in the book
explain why well let me explain a couple
things why it isn't identified in in
writing this book I mean I had to make
that that I made a very precise decision
that there would be no I in the book I
there was no I because I didn't want
this book to be about my impressions of
of Donald Trump I wanted it to be the
impressions of the people around him I
really and nobody believes this but I
went into this into this project without
without a preconception without an
assumption about about
whether Donald Trump could would be
successful or would be a failure I
thought I don't know and and I wanted to
find out what Donald Trump is who he is
through the people who worked with him
on a on a daily and often
minute-by-minute basis so I eliminated
myself from the book so anyway this this
dinner did occur at my house it came
about because I have had a relationship
with Roger Ailes for a long time for
almost 20 years and an Roger a man who I
don't would would not say I agreed with
on probably any any point on the
continuum of opinions has ever
nevertheless been a good friend a good
source an incredibly funny person to
spend time with and and and someone
through whom you really get a glimpse
you you really get to know something
about how how how power has worked over
this this practically speaking a
generation so I have known Roger when he
was thrown out of Fox I was perhaps
among the few people who kept speaking
to him and and he was moving to to to
Palm Beach in January he was going on
January 4th I said come for dinner on
the night before Roger and his and his
wife on the spur of the moment I think
probably that day I shot Steve Ben and I
know I said Roger is coming for dinner
he's moving too they're moving to Palm
Beach next day do you want to come and I
don't know what I expected out of that
but when I went when he responded that
he would he would like to come and then
I
to go to my wife and say guess who's
coming to dinner but it was actually
kind of us kind of a splendid evening
and and it was completely off the record
then Roger died and I thought what what
is that what does that mean than this
thing and I decided that that it
probably I decided I could use it and I
spoke to Roger's wife and it was a kind
of like yeah why there's so the cover
the confidentiality died with him
I yes I mean that was the decision that
I that made what right or wrong that was
a decision I made then shortly after
that actually I got this wrong because
first it was Steve Bannon who said after
Roger had died he said you're gonna use
that aren't you he said that's that's
that's history that's and I said oh oh
okay I that could and he said yeah use
it and then I spoke to Roger's wife so
that's how it got on the record okay and
so that is one of the scene setting
moments and so now we understand how it
is that you were able to get waved in to
the White House to basically become a
potted plant in the West Wing Lobby so
most of your your your meetings at the
White House were with Steve Bannon or at
least you were scheduled to meet with
Steve Bannon and then what would happen
no I was I was scheduled to meet with I
mean all right I've had a lot of
meetings with it with it with Steve and
Steve was one of the one of the pillars
of this this book but I basically met
with everybody and everybody was under
the impression that they were supposed
to meet with me
where do they get this impression from
did that
Gretchen come from the president or did
it because you were talking to Steve
Benin they figured well we should
probably came from it came from I mean I
mean I I was introduced around by by by
various people by hope Hicks who was the
you know I mean the president's kind of
personal PR person you know Kellyanne
Conway Sean Spicer I mean this was a
this was not a it was not a mystery here
now I think on one level nobody quite
knew how this came about and everybody
looked a little puzzled by things but it
it was there was no friction here there
was no friction no friction nobody was
saying what are you doing here everybody
was saying oh okay yeah yeah yeah yes
they would see you sitting they would
see you sitting in the West Wing Lobby
and who you're waiting to see yeah and
they would say but you would say Bannen
and they would they would chuckle and
say well that's not gonna happen or that
be for a while
why don't you come come back and talk to
me I mean I became a familiar presence
around the White House and and I think
also a very much a non-threatening
presence I mean I was not I mean you
know the the you know the press corps is
is it was over there I mean not not far
away but I was always careful not to
come in as a member of the press and not
to not to act like a member that you
know the the press is a sort of you know
they want something I didn't want
anything I I literally was just I didn't
even have a baby come on Michael I
didn't want anything I'm just sitting in
the West Wing Lobby hoping to talk to
all these man I just wanted I just
wanted someone to talk to me I was like
and this is this is actually an
important thing because it because you
go in there and it used to be so so it
would be in you know you'd get a I don't
know a 10 o'clock appointment you'd go
in and and then you would sit there and
you would sit there sometimes for hours
and sometimes hours and hours and it was
kind of humiliating actually and you had
the feeling that people took you know
regarded me as a kind of a pitiable
creature you know I'm not I'm not
important enough for anyone to keep
their appointment with me everybody else
is there and they're having appointments
and their people come out and I'm still
just waiting there and the hours are
passing and and I did feel feel
humiliated I was really I mean what and
but then it became this kind of thing
that people it began to work people
would stop and they would try to take
care of me and one of the neediest cases
come on you come back wait to me and and
in the other thing and this is an
important thing I I basically didn't ask
questions
so all reporters what do we do we ask
questions ask questions I don't ask
questions I go in and I sit there and
people just start to talk ok so what are
the reasons why perhaps people start to
talk from what you're saying and the key
in that is what you said in terms of the
initial part of your answer where you
said you mentioned hope hits who is the
president's personal PR person now when
you read fire and fury you find out that
everybody in this book has his or her
own PR person Jared and Ivanka have
their own PR person
Bannen ends up building up his own PR
team is one of the reasons why all the
president I mean
marry a president who has a press
secretary and the communications
communications shop of 40 people but
he's conducting his own freelance
operation so maybe one of the reasons
why people took pity on you as you sat
there as you say humiliated in the West
Wing Lobby they knew you were talking to
Bannon is it that they realize oh my god
he's talking to Bannon I need to talk to
him to find out what Bannon has said so
I can counteract that happened a little
later on when they realized that that
Bannon was kind of monopolizing me in
the beginning it was everybody everybody
was was was talking and confused about
why they were talking but they were
talking they they it could come on high
from nobody nobody actually knew from
where it came it seemed but there was a
general feeling that you were supposed
to talk to me I think for people
unburdening themselves it would did you
feel like a therapist well eventually
you did and that's the the I mean what I
saw and in the the I mean this this book
is is really about if there's a plotline
the transformation that took place is
people in the beginning who were you
know you know Donald Trump rah rah and
you know that you've got the Donald
Trump line and then that began to
degrade you know they began to give you
the the the the Trump line but that why
they were giving it to you they were
Gopal and it became very clear that they
wanted they wanted someone else to know
that why they had to give this line
they didn't believe it and then after
the moving even further on then it then
it fell apart entirely and then they
would tell you this is this is you know
this is really a mess here and so so I
mean I think that that happened in
then then the other thing that happened
was this was the Bandon thing that Steve
was talking to me so that so then other
people had to talk to me to counter what
Steve was saying and also because nobody
in the White House you know there were
these camps in the White House and those
camps didn't speak to each other so
therefore I became you had to in one
respect you had these camps saw an
advantage and speaking to me because
then they can ask me what the other
people were saying so I became a kind of
a messenger this is totally high school
and that was a welcome to Washington yet
I did mean in Tehran oh that's oh that
was it okay so you there are many
instances in the book where the
president picks up the phone and calls
around to his New York buddies or just
people and just Vince for a very long
time in one at the end of one chapter
one section you write about all the
things that the president said and then
at the end you said the call lasted 26
minutes how many people does the
president call like that back in New
York you know there are probably eight
people in New York he calls on a on a
steady basis I mean there may be more
those servers were sort of the ones you
know a people people I know about and I
you know I think he has you know he has
a I mean there's s that's his kitchen
cabinet of basically billionaires or a
few people media people who who who he
knows and you know and then I mean the
interesting thing is that he calls them
and then they call each other and then
whoever and then they call their friends
and so on and
then this this this all leaks out and so
the president you know throws a fit
about the leaks but of course in many
instances they come directly from him so
if you were if you are at the event I
did with Dan Rather back in November you
know I like to write in my books and
take notes so if you have your book with
you please turn to page 92 and there it
says On February 6th Trump made one of
his seething self-pitying and
unsolicited phone calls without
presumption of Quebec and
confidentiality to a passing New York
media acquaintance the call had no
discernable point other than to express
his bent out of shape feelings about the
relentless contempt of the media and the
disloyalty of his staff so of course I
immediately thought are you the passing
New York media acquaintance Michael and
and I believe so I told you in the and
in the greenroom I was not going to tell
you that III had to ask but you know
what then that question am I reading
that paragraph and that question gets to
something that I wonder if people
particularly here in Washington fully
appreciate and that is the fact that you
are a fixture in New York media you are
a fixture in New York society writ large
that the world that the president and
Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner the world
that they live in and socialize in is
the same world that you are in because
of that that sounds terrible
well no I don't mean it to be terrible
I'm thinking of it from a journalistic
point of view that when you read this
book there are nuggets of information
that only a quintessential New Yorker
only a New Yorker who who swims in that
who all would know the the the chapter
on Jar Vanka I think you have it the
what you write about Jared Kushner and
who he is and where he comes from and
why he bought the New York Observer and
why that was important and how Jared
Kushner and president Trump are very
similar that's not something you get
from just starting to work on this book
that's years if not decades of accrued
knowledge and in intelligence from being
a reporter in New York no yeah I mean so
I mean listen this is the world the
world I've lived in and reported on is
essentially the media world and Donald
Trump is in essentially a media figure I
mean he's not a political figure he
comes out of this world and in fact you
know I mean the president has been
saying that he doesn't know me and in
fact I have known him for four I guess
about twenty more than twenty years that
because I was the media columnist for
New York magazine and so I was one of
the people at the magazine that he would
regularly call up to complain about what
was written about him or more frequently
when he had not been written about and
you know and then I would I would see
him as see him often around town and he
was a diet of any gathering didn't like
to talk to uh you know like to talk to
people he knew he recognized and so I
you know we had a you know a perfectly
fine long acquaintance and which kind of
you know well I interviewed him in June
of 2016
just just before the conventions and in
an IRA so and I was I was brought we we
met the Kimmel
show in Los Angeles and and so I was
sort of brought in to interview him and
and I think it was Hope Hicks said said
mr. Trump you have you have 45 minutes
and his face went back his eyes went
open he says you don't give Michael
Wolfe 45 minutes
and then he said why don't you come back
to the house after I do the show and and
we'll sit around which we did for like
hours and eating his as he ate these
pints of ice cream well let's talk more
about president shrub and and media
because I do think that we have our fur
we have a a president who is a media
creation and you are someone who as you
just said writes about the media and you
write on page 215 this is president
Trump's even citizen Trump's view if you
couldn't get pressed directly for
yourself you became a leaker there was
no happenstance news in Trump's view all
news was manipulated and designed
planned and planted all news was to some
extent fake he understood that very well
because he himself had faked it so many
times in his career this was why he has
so naturally caught into the fake news
label quote I've made up I've made stuff
up forever and they always printed he
bragged that is the that we have seen
that totally I mean for 360
three days I mean his in I mean his
entire media career to be somewhat
distinguished from his real estate
career but his media career was about it
was about this was literally sort of I
will say anything that gets me Inc what
we used to call Inc yeah yeah and and it
was a was I mean it literally didn't
matter and even when you were on the
phone with him as a reporter it would on
the pretense would would would basically
fall what do you want me to say how do
you want me to play this this is this is
you know he's a he's another he's an old
in some sense he isn't just an
old-fashioned publicist so it's not him
that's you know that's his the
immorality of this is a well ingrained
accepted immorality in the in in and how
you get pressed for yourself that's the
that's the the you know the tabloid
business speaking of immorality so
you're sitting there in the in the west
wing lobby for hours on end and if
you've ever sat in the West Wing Lobby
you know that people are walking through
back and forth staffers are walking
through meetings people who have
meetings with senior staffers are coming
in I mean you have to it's it's the it's
one of the ways that you for the various
wings of the west wing um you know
upstairs the anyway you patted say it's
an easy pass through now you you you
we're hoping that someone would take
pity on you and see you and say and take
care of you but sitting in that Lobby
you see and hear an awful lot of things
while you are waiting everything did you
really you know I mean did you hear did
you hear them talking about policy just
in general policy and then I'll hone in
yeah
yes and were they speaking about policy
in any kind of substantive way and what
were they talking about yeah I mean it's
more you know I think the most riveting
thing I heard was like oh my god
is I heard Tony Blair and Jared Kushner
talking about the problems of the Middle
East and and I heard Jared Kushner say
let me get this right um
damn it we can solve this problem okay
and what was - and what was the former
prime minister his reaction he was I I
mean I think he he was acting like a man
who was trying to cultivate a new client
oh okay did you hear while sitting there
in the West Wing Lobby waiting for
someone to to come scoop you up and
bring and bring you upstairs or around
the bend
did you ever hear people talk about the
American people or particularly the
president's supporters in ways that you
found galling shocking appalling no I
mean actually my impression is that
mostly they didn't talk about things
outside of of the West Wing mostly they
were talking everybody in my experience
was almost wholly focused on what was
going on in the West Wing so the ban and
people were talking about the the the
Jovanka people there Ivanka people were
talking about the ban and people
everybody was talking about Reince
Priebus and and that's what I mean that
was I think I mean one of the things
that I that the I mean the lasting
impressions is that everybody was
focused on themselves is there anyone in
the White House who's left there's not a
lot of people who you've written about
who are gone who's actually qualified to
perform the job for which they were
hired or that the job they're doing now
well yeah I mean I think sure sugar I
mean there's I mean HR McMaster I think
is a is a you know I mean certainly an
experienced person in this job even you
know Mick Mulvaney yeah you know there
are there are a lot there are
professional people there but you know
one of the things I think I think it's
really worth focusing on now which
hasn't gotten enough attention is that
is that with with all of the the the
initial team leaving ban and previous
Spicer you
you're left the basically the to the
president's to senior most advisors our
hope Hicks 28 or 29 of June a former
junior fashion PR person and Stephen
Miller who everybody saw his head
explode on with an example
national television I mean in these mean
whether you agree with them or their
politics or not these are just just two
people who bring nothing to this to this
to this table they just have no
experience no maturity and you know and
no reason no reason Under the Sun to be
having to be doing the jobs that that
we're paying them to do now a central
focus of the book is Steve Bannon is
throughout this book Steve Bannon is the
smartest person in the West Wing
Steve Bannon is the one who's the true
believer who has an agenda who wants to
push the president to do what he thinks
he should do Steve Bannon is smarter
than trevan cos smarter than previous
smarter than speiser smarter than than
everybody bannon's gone are you
surprised
given the way he comes off here he comes
off as someone who really thinks he's
smarter than he really is are you
surprised that he is no longer there and
not just no longer there like
excommunicated the Bursar's have even
left him III think that I saw Steve
comes
I do think Steve is smart and and again
was not mollified to be in that job
excuse was he qualified to be in that
job that he had well you know Steve is
64 years old and has never worked in in
politics or government before so I would
say in no conventional terms was he
qualified for this
nevertheless he had at least read a few
books so he's coming in the bar is very
low here alright before I'm gonna ask
this one last question and I think we're
gonna open it up to Q&A from the
audience because I've lost track of time
and I'm so afraid that I am going to
take time away from you so I'm gonna say
this now before I ask this last question
if you have a question there's a mic
there and a mic there please line up to
ask your question one make sure it's a
question there will be no speeches if
there are speeches I don't mean to be
rude but I will be forced to cut you off
and I'll be rude about it
because I want to get in as many people
as possible so again there's a
microphone here and a microphone there
Michael
you claimed a one interview you left
some quotes and some stories out why I
just couldn't nail it I mean things that
I that I believe to be true but but
couldn't nail it that's was there
anything so shocking that you nailed it
but because it was so shocking you kept
it out well yes I mean there's wait what
wait there right there is there there
are several things that I thought were
shocking I believe that I had nailed it
but they were shocking enough that you
need to needed a sort of a triple
quadruple nailing and and I didn't have
that animal vegetable mineral who which
camp did it come from what are you
trying to suss out what is this shocking
thing that you left out that you nailed
that you left it out
you're giving give me some contours you
know you have no idea I know that's
right now I know how much I have to
struggle not to tell you but but I will
tell you if you read the book and if you
read between the lines it is there so
just so just a little test okay is it at
the beginning the middle or the end it's
it's toward the end I would say no more
cuz you'll get it out of me here and
this will be you know then we'll all oh
I can keep going I can totally sell the
Q&A if I can squeeze this out of you
[Applause]
does it involve
okay so questions and well I'm gonna let
you I'm gonna let you off the hook for
now
okay who was it it just you just read
it's there if you're just patient and
you just see just read it's it's like a
good reading thing it's there you were
first in about nobody nobody has yet
spotted it you were first in line you
get the first question
emphasis on question thank you very much
hi Michael thanks for the book you
achieved what all of us were thinking
about which was boy we wish we were
flying the wall in the White House you
were that fly in the wall so thank you
for sharing my question is on the
average how many days a week were you
able to get into the White House and
procedurally how did you get in
yeah procedurally turns out to be easy
you make an appointment whoever you make
an appointment that your first
appointment with put you into the system
and and you go in and then you're
basically there for the day so you have
to start out you have to make in a you
have to go in with an appointment I
didn't go in
you know I didn't have run of this free
run I mean once you you did as soon as
you got in which you had to make this
appointment so I would actually spend
Monday's my schedule was Monday's I
would make my appointments for the week
and then I live in New York so then I
would come down on either Monday night
or very early Tuesday morning
I would check into the hay-adams which
is right across from the White House and
then I would I would go back and forth
and though in the the nice thing which I
quickly found about about the hay-adams
is that is that a lot of people in the
end of the day would come over come over
for a drink or or dinner or whatever
well we always wear that fly don't we
thank you question here thank you for
coming out so prior to the campaign I
mean it's pretty clear that Trump and
the Clinton family had a pretty
extensive relationship I mean Hillary
had received donations from Donald
through her numerous campaign
they were both president at her wedding
etc etc at the start of the book you
mentioned that a lot of the ambitions of
the Trump team fell apart at once he won
the presidency I mean it was clear he
was trying to now it's a cable news
network at that sort of thing do you
think Clinton was knowledgeable of
Trump's ambitions given their
relationship prior to the campaign and
do you think she had formed her campaign
in a way to accommodate those ambitions
I'm I'm not clear on the question you
asked that question again but shorter
okay yeah so Donald and Hillary had a
relationship prior to the campaign right
Donald was clearly he clearly had other
motives aside from being the president
right do you think Hillary was
knowledgeable of those motives when she
was shaping her campaign yeah well I
mean I don't I mean I mean fundamentally
you know the the Trump the Trump people
didn't think that they were gonna win
and the Clinton people didn't think the
Trump people were gonna win right so in
in that respect I mean I think that the
that the Hillary people probably
probably did assume that that the Trump
people had other ambitions beside being
president which they weren't gonna do or
theoretically they weren't gonna be and
as he writes in the in the book all
those the Trump ambitions were the Trump
television network and Ivanka had her
own ambitions and Jared had his own own
ambitions but thank you for your
question question here hi Michael
thank you for doing this interview my
question was what's the part of the book
that you ultimately wish that you had
cut out and why the the that you wish
you had cut out a part of the book that
you ended up leaving in but looking back
you wish that you have cut I am no part
I think it's I would say that that I am
entirely happy with the book at this
point you know when you write books
years from now you look back and you
think but at this moment in time I'm
feeling good
yeah you probably want to put that piece
in
that you say you'd let that I think I
forgot about that Michael was it
Tillerson question here you need to take
lessons on the pitiable creature thing
apparently my question is about the
petiole question creature aspect of
sitting in the white and the West Wing
Lobby so you're sitting there are you on
your phone are you working on things are
you just like making puppy eyes and
anybody who walks by you hoping that
like are you really going going for
trying to like catch somebody's
attention while you're sitting in the
West Wing Lobby or are you doing your
own thing and eventually I'm trying not
to be not to be noticed because you're
trying not to be noticed because you
think somebody's gonna throw you out you
know like like what are you doing here
and you're trying not to be noticed
because you know it's embarrassing you
know there you are you know the clock
you know there's people there and the
clock goes and you know you've in a
gower has passed beyond your appointment
and and then they try to say can I get
you anything can you do this and then
there was the issue of going in the
bathroom which then that becomes you
know can you just go to the bathroom and
though it turns out you can you just go
and you can wander almost anywhere wait
a minute we're I'm trying to think I've
send that West Wing Lobby where do you
where is the bathroom that you can get
to underscored it with unless courted
its you you go through the the when you
walk in the door on the left
you go through the door which actually
leaves them to the yeah the Roosevelt
Room and then the in the Oval I mean
it's again it was the thing you know
what are they gonna see you right and
you don't happen as you said before you
don't have a press pass you have been
the blue appointment badge which I guess
gives you some other kind of you know
access to the bathroom
question here thank you Michael I've
been wondering as someone who's in the
media yourself who's been your favorite
press secretary
just lots of my favorite press secretary
your favorite press secretary yeah I
mean I've only really dealt with in the
in this way this this book I only dealt
with with Sean so you know after so and
I I didn't have actually any dealings
with with Sarah so but did you mean
press secretaries in general because men
in this administration the three of the
three ok so Sean Spicer awesome thank
you all right thank you
question here and now
Robert mullah and his team they wants to
talk with Benin and definitely they will
ask Benin about these things that you
thought of him for in the book you have
met Trump and Benin and their
relationship is not very good at the
moment it seems like but we're not
completely sure what is your impression
that will ban on cell Trump indeed when
when he talks with mobile Robin Miller
or will he connect or will he confirm
what he said what is your impression
what will happen from now on well let's
look at this think yeah in in in two
ways I would anticipate that that that
Steve will tell the truth you know but I
guess I guess there's the truth and
there's the truth does he does he does
he really go after the president does
Steve Bannon make the decision to try to
break Trump and I think I think that you
know if if if I were Steve right now
that's what I would be if I would be
thinking that's one of my options here I
mean I I literally saw Steve ban and
go from from the guy who elected Trump
to the guy who thought that Trump was
was was the the idiot of the century and
and the and a guy who you know you know
who who who came to realize that
whatever goals and an agenda
Steve had whatever he you know the
nationalist populace would whatever that
is and I don't mean to be dismissive for
for Steve that is a very very specific
idea driven program and he thought that
Trump would be its trump would be able
to lead this this this new movement and
it turned out Trump really is not
capable of that not interested in that
and is is is is is just gonna go in
whatever direction he goes in at any
given moment and I think Steve found
that incredibly infuriating and I think
that he was using the things he said in
my book as part of his intention to
break with Trump
so I yes I think I think that he I don't
know what's gonna happen but I think
it's a very real possibility that Steve
could sink in resident and to follow up
on his question
since he brought up Robert Muller has
anybody on Muller's team contacted you
in connection with the investigation at
all given some of the things you have in
here such as bannon's quote that the the
meeting in June in Trump Tower was
treasonous they have not but I'll be
honest I mean I've gotten a lot I'm
really behind on my email question here
thank you thank you you mentioned you
have tapes of the discussions with mr.
bannon and the House Intelligence
Committee has subpoenaed him eagerly the
question is have you considered if you
receive a subpoena for those tapes if
you would provide them and have you
considered whether if you do you would
release them publicly at the same time I
I have I mean the answer as I haven't
considered have not considered I have
not considered what I would do if that
if if my tapes were subpoenaed and and
you know and then that brings up this
other problem and the whole idea of of
the tapes and releasing tapes because if
my tapes were ever subpoenaed I would
not release them so and I think that
that's that's you know that's just it's
part of what we do as as as journalists
I can't think of anything more
fundamental that that about how you
protect your your work so just another
aspect of this tape question which is
seems to me ultimately unclear question
here do you believe that the P tape is
real wait I didn't hear I didn't hear
the question either so you believe that
the P tape is real do you believe that
the P tape is real
I would have no way of knowing my gut is
I don't believe it
but that's just divine I mean I'm in are
my god
did it did anyone I mean I can't even
just imagining it and
Michael yes in in any of your
conversations with any of the people in
the West Wing
did anyone ever bring it up the P tape I
mean yes but in somewhat of an a in in
elliptical ways and there was a lot of a
lot of I you know can you um I mean
there's a lot of stuff can you imagine
this can it no no it's not possible
and I have actually I've had the
disconcerting experience of actually
having discussed this with the President
of the United States okay now we're
talking we're putting some extra time on
the clock here Michael it was what what
did the President of the United States
say did he bring it up on his own he
brought it up on his own in what okay I
was embarrassed I didn't want to talk
about about you know golden showers with
the president I probably should I just
and I felt so awkward about this what
did he say he said that he was a
germaphobe and he didn't believe he
couldn't believe that people were
accusing him of this and and and did I
think it was true
you know me he said you can you see me
doing that I just didn't know what to
say I was like that was just one of a
litany of things in this phone call or
did he call you specifically to say you
don't think that this is true I have a
germophobe
did you get the sense that the president
was trying to convince you that he
couldn't possibly do this I think that
the president just talks off his head I
don't think he's trying to convince
anybody of anything I don't think he has
no strategy in what he's saying he has
no intention or intend I think it just
it just it just comes out and I don't
think it really matters who he's talking
to and he certainly doesn't listen to
who he's talking to so what does it
matter
but it's a very disconcerting experience
to speak to Donald Trump to say the very
least so this particular PP taped
conversation when did that happen I will
not I wonder did that Hatter not to say
did that happen when did it happen as
Republican nominee did it happen as
president-elect did it happen as
president of the United States although
you said it's disconcerting to have a
conversation like that he was the
President of the United States that's
within within the last 363 days yes
it's your turn
hi how do we get Donald Trump out of
office patience I mean I think he'll get
himself out of office it's it's this is
just an unfolding process from the
beginning of this Trump thing you know
we've solved seen this as a as a train
wreck and it's just that the wall seemed
to recede but the wall is still there
you say he'll get himself himself out of
office does that mean you don't buy the
the prayers for impeachment you don't
buy the really big prayers for
invocation of the 25th amendment you
think that he will figure out a trumpian
way to resign or leave the presidency a
winner
I think the Bannen formula is very
reasonable a 33 and a third percent
chance they'll be impeached a 33 and a
third percent chance that he will resign
in the shadow of the 25th amendment a 33
and a third percent chance that he will
limp to the end but a 0% chance that he
will have another term or even run again
question here sort of in the same vein I
was gonna ask you when and how will this
end and you can talk we can talk about
impeachment but there's also others who
could be involved in I know you don't
have a crystal ball but where do you see
well I know I think I'll fall back on
that I mean I think literally the ban
and formula is it is the most reasonable
way to look at this I mean we don't know
how this is gonna end but we can I have
some confidence really something near
absolute confidence that it will end
question here hi Michael thanks for the
discussion two questions first can you
kind of go into more of the beginning of
your Benin's relationship how did that
come about and then second have you
received an influx in hate mail or have
you talked to the president I said I
have you received an influx of hate mail
and or have you spoke to the president
since the release of this book have you
had any positive an influx of hate mail
and why people flux of hate mail have
you got an Indian some hate mail have
you spoken to the president since the
book I I have not and and I really
haven't gotten hate mail but again as I
say I'm really a mind on the email I
mean the first question was can you talk
about elaborate more on the beginning of
your in bannon's relationship how that
came up you mentioned a dinner but I'm
sure that's something your your
relationship with Bannen how did that
come about okay
in February or March of 2016 I was
walking through the the Orlando Airport
because I was going to give some
speeches when you're when you're on the
speaking circuit you're always happy to
go to Orlando anyway I'm walking through
and I'm not paying much much much
attention but somebody there's there's a
guy I see this guy who who clearly seems
to recognize me and looks at me and in
fact he drops his bags and and he comes
over to me kind of home he embraces me I
think you know and he says he says oh
you you've been doing great work and you
know I'm you know you take a fan in
anyway you get them yeah and I say thank
you thank you this and that and but he's
acting like I like I know like we know
each other and also that at my age this
happens also when you think okay I just
um but then that was it that's all I
knew then about a month later I saw an
article about bright bar and there was a
picture of this guy and I thought oh my
god the guy who hugged me in Orlando is
the Breitbart guy uh and I I still
wrestle with this have have I ever known
Steve man and how could this pie I don't
know but and I didn't think anything
beyond that except then it comes around
it comes August and suddenly Steve
Bannon is appointed the head of the
Trump campaign I thought okay if he
thinks I'm his friend I'll be his friend
and
and I write him an email and he says
come up any time and which I promptly do
I mean this is not far from my house I
go over I go over there go up up to
Trump Tower and we sit down and and it's
and it's it seems like we're friends I
mean I missed the whole chapter here but
yeah and we have a in that sustain so
he's there maybe this is the second week
he's there and then he said he says
we're gonna win you know and he outlines
we're gonna win you know our path is
through is through Florida Ohio Michigan
and Pennsylvania and this seems so much
just like you know silliness that I
don't even write this and and then I
feel kind of you know so my I don't I'm
mmm maybe I exchanged another couple of
emails with with him but then they win
and I respond again I say can I come up
and he says yes so oh I think a week or
so after the election maybe two weeks I
I go up there we sit down we have a
conversation and and and I say can I
write this and he says no and then I
said you know somebody's gonna write
this you know you are about to be them
one of the most famous people in the
country and he said okay right
so I did and that was actually the first
the first I think that was the first on
the record interview that Steve gave and
it may actually been the forbidden of
the the only one he gave until until
just before he he left the White House
and and so we I just continued this this
relationship our deep friendship which I
don't know where it came from but before
we moved to this next question here do
you fee do you feel badly that the book
is what helped push Bannon out oh yeah I
feel I feel that Steven knew what he was
doing I feel badly that he's seen is
clearly at a some place where he did not
expect to be I feel sure however that he
has a plan to get where he wants to be
the three people in that line are the
final three people short questions yes
you've known him as you say for over two
decades for close to six years so he's
changed from being a Democrat to an
independent to a very right-wing
Republican does the man have any true
ideology or is it just spur of the
moment and what gets him bingo
[Laughter]
that's what fire and fury is all about
no we I'm sorry ma'am we are so over
time and I want to give the bearded man
behind you a chance to a chance to ask
his question thank you I read that there
was some serious discussion of
developing your book into a television
series and I'm curious to know as much
about that as you can share but
specifically I'm curious about what kind
of tone you envision for that whether it
be a dark comedy or dark drama
good I think your book can be read
either way you know I mean I've I've had
enough involvement to it with with
Hollywood to know that that whatever the
writer of the wants is totally
irrelevant um
if I if I could I would say you play a
totally straight I mean you you don't
have to do anything here just it can it
carries itself thanks I can't wait to
put tune it hey it's you again
can I have another question really a
sort yes question
if Donald Trump get impeached then it
would be Mike Pence it will he be better
for us then Donald III and can answer
that I had no idea I mean I I think
anything would be better but I mean that
falls into the category of be careful
what you wish for
so Michael laugh I last question
President Trump tweeted not recently but
when the book came out Michael Wolfe is
a total loser who made up stories in
order to sell this really boring and
untruthful book he used sloppy Steve
been and who cried when he got fired and
begged for his job now sloppy Steve has
been dumped like a dog by almost
everyone too bad
[Laughter]
if the president were here right now or
or or called you what would you say to
him the thing about talking and Donald
Trump is that you never get to say
anything to him but I predict that
actually what he will say sooner rather
than later is that he is responsible for
this book it's successful because of him
and and he is the real writer of this
book and on that note Michael Wolfe
thank you both so much if you could all
please remain seated while our guests
exit